no one should feel sorry for me either
from a positive or negative perspective
I've had a great life I've had a great
career and I've had a career that most
actors would really eel would die for so
no one has to feel sorry for me I'm
doing fine Cosby Show alum Jeffery Owens
stopped by Good Morning America and
opened up about the attention he's
received since photos of him working at
a grocery store in New Jersey went viral
it's really overwhelming it's it's in a
good way
but I mean it's I kind of feel like that
that character in that Woody Allen movie
that wakes up one morning and he's a
celebrity over the 57 year old said that
he was initially upset by several news
outlets that he claims job shamed him
until celebrities and fans jumped to his
defense on social media I mean I was I
was really devastated but it lasted it
was the period of devastation was so
short because so shortly after that the
response is my wife and I started to
read these responses from like literally
all over the world of support and and so
fortunately the shame part didn't last
very long
Owens who worked at the grocery store
for 15 months said he took the job
because he wanted flexible hours in
order to stay in the entertainment
business people recognized me every day
and they were very very cool about it
now Owen says he hopes his experience
will help reshape how people think I
hope what doesn't pass is this idea that
people are now thinking this rethinking
about what it means to work you know the
honor of the working person and the
dignity of work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]